avec christian jacob avec lé député de
l'oise et au nom de l'ensemble des
députés de notre groupe
je souhaite rendre hommage à notre
collègue et ami olivier dassault mes
chers collègues olivier dassault le
disait récemment malgré le choc
la houle et légumes virevoltante le
soleil percera à travers les nuages de
la tempête malgré la tristesse qui nous
étreint tous aujourd'hui soyons fidèle à
son message d'espoir et d'optimisme
la semaine dernière nous avons assisté
stupéfaits à une nouvelle manifestation
de l'islamo gauchisme dans
l'enseignement supérieur alors que la
gauche se victimise sur ce concept et
que les petits censeurs tente de se
faire passer pour les censurer
rappelons que l'islamo gauchisme est une
réalité décrite depuis des années
notamment par le politologue pierre
andré taguieff qu'allez vous faire face
à ces attaques insupportables
allez vous enfin dissoudre les syndicats
étudiants qui partent qu'ils propagent
ces discours de haine école des cibles
sur le dos de ses enseignants
l'enseignement je le crois et je pense
que nous en sommes tous convaincus est
et doit rester le creuset de la
république et de la nation et on ne peut
pas accepter sans réagir
qu'il devienne l'incubateur du
séparatisme et d'ivoire des enseignants
placés sous protection policière
les habitants du pas de calais 93
mesures fortes un des vaccins pas pour
rattraper le retard
mais pour prendre de l'avancé sur
l'épidémie 2 la fin du deux poids deux
mesures entre paris et la province
3 la possibilité de déroger
temporairement au couvre-feu à 18 heures
pour faire ses courses afin de mieux
lisser les jauges dans les magasins
alimentaires et limiter la propagation
d'épidémies
nous n'avons tout ce qu'un seul souhait
c'est lui que la campagne s'accélère
nous disposons d'une force de frappe
considérable qui ne demande qu'à être
sollicités au premier rang de laquelle
les médecins mais aussi les pharmaciens
et les pompiers dans la mobilisation
pourrait permettre de multiplier par dix
les capacités de vaccination
les français en ont assez de la
communication bavarde assez des
décisions multiples sur le nombre de
français vaccinés ou dite accélérée la
vaccination
nous aussi nous le voulons nous
n'acceptons plus les autosatisfaction
qui sont trahis par les décisions de
votre administration ordres et contre
ordres en tissant ce qui décrédibilise
la guerre contre le virus
mettons fin au silence mettant fin aux
discriminations neyton fort aux
violences faisons l'égalité
femmes/hommes une réalité pour la plage
notre combat ne doit jamais cesser en
matière de police et de justice
il ne s'agit pas de répondre au coup par
coup mais de mettre en place une
véritable politique sérieuse et
cohérente
il faut cesser les effets de
communication comme le bobo de la sécu
était il est temps d'agir ce qu'il faut
monsieur le ministre c'est sanctionner
fermement les individus responsables
démanteler cette voyoucratie en pleine
crise sanitaire et économique
il est aujourd'hui devenu urgent de
protéger notre industrie nationale tant
fragilisé en effet les emplois dans
certains secteurs industriels sont
désormais gravement menacée tandis que
les pratiques commerciales déloyales
continue à se développer
rendant plus qu'incertaine la situation
de nos entreprises
le président de la république avait
promis la création de 15000 places de
prison pendant son quinquennat si les
objectifs annoncés avaient été tenus on
ne parlerait peut-être pas de
surpopulation carcérale en france les
délais de remboursement partiel des
matches achetés par les collectivités
force est de constater que dans mon
département 25 % des communes sont
toujours en attente
je vais nous donner l'occasion cet
après-midi d'essayer d'anticiper sur le
remboursement des charges liées aux
centres de vaccination
[Musique]
oh